well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
consultant editor
of the daily mail andrew pearce and the
associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire
welcome and great to see you both
as ever though we start with the front
pages the metro
leading with the transport secretary
grant shops insisting
it is premature for people to plan on
booking a getaway this summer
their headline holds on hold
one in five vaccinated the uk leads the
way for the rest of the world that's the
front of the eye
the preston journal has word that the
number of scots vaccinated against covet
19 is now
more than a million according to the
guardian the prime minister is facing
criticism that the
3.5 billion pound package aimed at
tackling dangerous cladding
in high-rise buildings does not go far
enough
while the financial times reports that
amsterdam has now surpassed
london as the biggest stock trading
center in
europe on a similar note the telegraph
quotes the governor of the bank of
england
asserting that it would be a mistake for
the eu to exclude the uk
from the european banking community the
sun leads with an exclusive it says how
a forklift
driver spent more than 175 000
pounds using a manchester city players
bank card awaiting more papers they are
late in entrepreneurs kevin mcguire are
here
um but the ones we have bit of a mixed
bag but let's start with that
debate about holidays as everyone tries
to shape
their summer no such luck andrew
well it's um talk about mixed signals so
a month ago we had the health secretary
proudly telling us he he and his family
are going to cornwall very nice
vince cormor went there last year uh uh
and then we have grant chaps the
transport secretary
you ought to know all about trance
afterwards saying
don't book a holiday abroad and don't
have a staycation either
uh don't book one now to avoid
disappointment so
how long these restrictions are going on
we don't know it's very disappointing
because people are
we need something to look forward to
anna we're looking forward to a break
we're looking forward to getting away
my partner and i have ruled out any idea
of catching a plane this year
it's a hideous experience these days
anyway but particularly we don't want to
get caught up in
redless countries and and quarantining
and having to stay in a vowel hotel near
gatwick airport when we get back for 750
pounds or 10 days
so we're planning the staycation and
then the transport secretary says
don't bother so who's right and boris
had a chance at the press at the downer
street briefing tonight to
um put uh to contradict the transport
secretary
because because he did not yes he did
not because
the kent virus itself is obviously more
transmissible
the other variants are clearly worrying
people left right and center
so so why you know set your set your
stall out just
yet when you know your road map is
coming in in just over a week kevin
yeah he essentially said that we haven't
got long awaited the week after next
he'll come up with his road map and i'm
sure that'll be
very tentative he's in road maps in the
past have been
roads to nowhere you'll be very careful
with this one but i think you could have
a kind of intelligent grown-up public uh
debate
and you don't need the health secretary
and the transport secretary
contradicting each other which they they
are
and the prime minister just swerved uh
really concided with either although i
suppose because
grant shap spoke out today and said
don't book
the very fact the promiser didn't
endorse him i think suggests he's going
the other way
and will hope to open up the country
school is going to go back in
england planned in the week of uh 8th
8th of march
then after that will be a program for
allowing outdoor events then pubs
restaurants cafes at some point so
i would have thought he's thinking yes
people will be able to go on holiday in
the summer but not quite sure when
that's going to start
and what you can do and so but you can
have that debate all you have to do is
say look it's all very tentative
uh i would hope you can go on holiday in
the summer but if you book it you've got
to be prepared for a cancellation
um i suspect those who are running
hotels guest houses caravan
parks campsites everything would quite
like some bookings and a bit of money
coming in they might have to pay it back
later but it would help with that cash
flow
so i think you should take us along in a
conversation but you have to put all the
caveats in
that it could change as you say the the
kent variation
another mutant uh virus that could be
just a big failure somewhere along along
the way by
by the government um test and trace is
still pretty poor but the nhs
vaccination program they don't call it
the nhs
vaccination program they call it nhs
testing trends is not nhs
but what is the nhs and is a real
success they don't call it
the nhs i wonder what's going on there
with this uh with this
nevertheless you've got you've got to
have that uh that conversation
and charles charles walker uh andrew
said he wants me to look forward to
charles walker
um the tory mp and he's vice chair of
the 1922 committee of adventures i
thought he's going to blow a gasket
today when he
was saying this this is terrible you've
got to give people something to look
forward to and i think it's quite right
it's all tentative you can book but you
might not be able to get there you might
get a cancellation but i think uh
encourage people to book if you think
it's gonna open
up and you take a chance i've uh i've
had several holidays that
that were booked and that'll be
cancelled because i wasn't allowed to
to go on and buy the government that's
but i just accepted that at the time
yes as long as people don't lose too
much money i suppose and many people
have got their rolled over holidays from
last year that got cancelled
anyway so they're still waiting for
those ones and weddings too
i mean bear that in mind yes sir charles
walker um would have been at the 1922
committee today wouldn't he this evening
where matt hancock once again repeated
that he was going on holiday to cornwall
at exactly the same time as boss johnson
was at
in the danny street news conference
saying that it was too early to book so
there's certainly the confusion for
people financial times is uh
picturing people in spain hoteliers
there many of which have closed
talking about being um you know looking
forward to the summer
and the difficulty is that really uk
tourists are not welcome now anyway
because of
because of the uk variant the kent
variant and
there's a paranoia about this south
african variant so all of it is up in
the air isn't it do we do we just have
to be patient
andrew or should those desperate
deposits be much needed for the for the
tourism industry do you think
no i i mean if i was advising friends
i'd say don't be
don't be catching a flight don't be
booking flames because it's
it's going to be very tricky who knows
uh so
think about your holiday in britain and
look i i
grant chats can say what he likes people
should make provisional plans
they've got to make plans particularly
if most people aren't going to have a
holiday in britain this year if
we start opening up because we think we
surely will for god's sake the vaccine
is being rolled out
it's a great extraordinary success eu
eat your heart out
13 million now we we've done and it the
whole point of the back scene it means
we can start to get back to normal
and that's what people have to look
forward to because people are very down
in the dumps
everybody you speak to says this
lockdown has proved much more difficult
much harder it seems to be going on for
a lot longer
and people are very down in the dumps
and you do need
rays of sunshine to look forward to you
wouldn't describe kevin mcguire's array
of sunshine to look forward to
but a week in bournemouth may yeah and
he's all we've got for now
to be fair
um and just confirmation today in terms
of better news on the vaccine
from the prime minister that the
intention is that all over 50s will be
vaccinated by the end of april so he
said that categorically today didn't he
let's move on shall we to the guardian
and just when the grenfell
inquiry is hearing some extraordinary
testimony
about the flammable cladding used in
this country
the government tackled it didn't it
throwing more money at the problem but
not enough for many people is the
accusation isn't it kevin
oh yeah it's quite serious uh accusation
because
of course they're stopping at 18 meters
so property is under
uh six stories uh that will get loans
not
uh not compensation so it's three and a
half billion but it but it isn't it
isn't enough and
it you put a 50 pound a month limit on
what
uh uh tenants might have to pay but
that's 600 a year and you're still to
have
great difficulty selling that property
on if you if you want to move
and uh stevenburg portland a
conservative backbench who
probably led the charge it was most
angry about it because
because the people who are not at fault
are the people who are living in those
those properties there are issues around
government regulations there are issues
about the companies making
the planning there's issues around who
put up those
those blocks but the people who are not
to blame are those sitting in there
sometimes owning them
and they can't they can't move them on
it's kind of
the government went some way with some
of the taller blocks but didn't it
didn't go
all the way and and again i think
there's gonna be so much criticism you
do wonder if down the line there will be
some switching some utah yeah and people
have
people have given horrible testimony
about this so andrew just just they
what they've said they've had to pay
night watchmen who stay up
all night to see whether there's going
to be a fire and they you know people
aren't sleeping and all of this i mean
it's been it's been terrible for people
for for
for some years since grenfell hasn't it
just yeah i mean look
they're living in properties which are
potentially flammable
and could go up in flames so they've got
that anxiety they're having to pay for
these night security guards who often
literally are asleep on the job so
aren't very good
and it isn't their fault and i don't
think the government
has look it's it's not the government's
haul either let's be quite clear about
that
property developers they're going to get
a tax whacked on them well they make
enough money so
how much money are they putting into the
pot i'm not clear about that
but there are literally tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of leaseholders who are going to be
financially out of pocket
50 pounds a month that could be over 25
years that's
thousands and thousands of pounds and
they're probably gonna have
property blight because they can't sell
their property they're in a nightmare
situation and i think
uh the government are gonna have to come
back to the commons and provide more
money i just don't think
this is sustainable not least because
all politics always creeps in here
a lot of these leaseholders are
potentially tory voters
in marginal seats and they will be very
very angry because
they have the prime minister saying
nobody should be out of pocket well they
are going to be out of pocket
to the tune of hundreds of thousands
yeah it certainly certainly feels like
something has gone wrong in the building
trade to allow all of this to be put up
when some of it
had that flammable content in it
certainly um plenty more still to come
and if you miss us talking about brexit
on this programme we did for years it
feels like
uh then wish us luck more on a big new
banking route after the break welcome
back you're watching the press preview
with me now andrew pierce and kevin
mcguire welcome back to both of you
um after uh all the debate about uh what
happens at dover what happens in
northern ireland what happened with the
fishing industry um
it all went a bit quiet on the city of
london didn't it kevin
not now it appears it's making the front
pages of a couple of the newspapers
including the telegraph
it is uh which of course is a big
backseat of uh
big brexit back in the paper but andrew
bailey governor of the bank of
england is accusing the european union
of trying to shut
out uk financial institutions uh
the telegraph records and the ft in fact
leads on how now amsterdam has overtaken
london as the
biggest trader of uh shares 9.2 billion
a day
worth of euros in amsterdam 8.6 billion
in in london it's because brussels isn't
allowing
eu financial institutions that air
shares traded elsewhere
well maybe this should have all been
thought about beforehand they
many of us may not like bankers but
nevertheless
uh they uh they pay a lot in tax for the
economy so they'll be missed i know it's
a big problem here
andrew bailey is trying to say oh it's
going to be bad for both sides of
the channel the eu and the uk it might
be might be right
but once you're out uh the eu you have
no complaints
if it's going to try and take your trade
just as the government
is uh hinting and stating that it wants
to take
eu trade now the uk is out of the
european union so it's it's doggy dog
but their dog is a lot bigger than our
dog do you want to do that or do you
want to get to the dog
andrew what can i can i just say on that
you see part of the problem here
is um the trade deal that was struck on
the 11th hour
with the european union did not include
um
services so uh so tourism and all the
rest of it
isn't covered by that but financial
services is and so that's all got to be
negotiated so that's part of the reason
why amsterdam has got its nose in front
on share deals
but what andrew bailey the governor of
the bank of england is saying if they
can restore something called equivalence
i've no idea what it means it's some
financial
technicality they can organize that
all can be peace in our time but it's a
big test here
relations between us and york brussels
have been appalling since we left
they behaved appallingly over the
vaccine they're behaving appallingly
over shellfish
and it seems like they're now going to
cut up rough over the city they may not
do so well there because
we have got one of the most accomplished
and sophisticated trade city trading
operations in the world
okay we will watch and wait and see what
happens with that to the dog that i was
talking about obviously
um three photographers being employed um
the dog
was it being taken by a taxpayer funded
photographer was the question
but this has all gone a bit deport
hasn't it um kevin tell us this story
it it has this this is boris johnson who
of course is a very very vain man adding
a yes he's got three taxpayer funded
photographers
on the downing street payroll uh taking
pictures of me dog in the
dog in the snow got released on flickr a
bit of a mistake because you could see
his uh
girlfriend carrie simon's telephone
number a mobile number on the collar
many people have you know if you find my
dog ring this bring this number
and so that was a bit of an error but
it's just it's this whole idea why
now i can see for state occasions you
might have photographers but your dog
when you're just trying to burnish your
credentials and look like a really nice
cuddly person it's a misuse of public
funds it should not be happening like
this they've
in number 10 they've been pushing uh
independent photographers
newspapers they've been pushing them out
and using just sending out propaganda
pictures but they've
gone too far it's like it's absolutely
barking they can get
get to to do this we will see you at
half eleven
bum indeed uh kevin andrew lovely as
ever thank you